before we get to the latest on
coronavirus i just want to start on
those new tragic stabbings that we've
seen in reading three people losing
their lives is there any update that you
can give us and could this become a
terrorism investigation well the police
are clearly investigating they do not
have not currently stated that this is a
terrorism investigation but rather a
murder investigation and I my heart goes
out to the to the families the Friends
of the victims and clearly it's a
shocking event the police did a
brilliant job last night firstly at the
during the event and then and then
afterwards and I think you know it's a
now it's now an operational matter for
the police and we should give them all
of the space and support that they need
in order to get to the bottom of it yeah
actually say much for the police that
now we'll be bringing you the very
latest on that on Sky News just as soon
as we get it as well and I want to talk
to you at now health secretary about the
next steps to easing the lockdown can
you confirm that from July the 4th if
the infection rate allows we'll be able
to go on holiday in the UK or get a
haircut well we have a clear plan for
how we get it and get out of the worst
parts of this lockdown
safely and I stress that word safely
it's absolutely critical we're working
through that plan the plan is so far and
currently working we can see the total
number of new transmissions coming down
and thankfully the number of people
dying from coronaviruses coming down the
number of people on ventilated beds in
hospital is coming down and so on Friday
the scientists were able to advise that
the that the alert level came down and
so we are on plan will of course be
setting out more details of that plan
and in the plan it states that on on
around the July the 4th we will take
further measures if it's safe to do so
and what could those further measures be
I'm asking because there are
speculations obviously and in May papers
today that would
about UK staycations we're talking about
hairdressers pubs what could the next
steps be what we talk about hospitality
and outdoor hospitality in that plan but
there's a there are a whole series of
other services especially those where
you need to be physically close to
somebody in order to carry it out like
like a haircut I mean a lot of the
country does need a haircut and we need
to do that in a safe way and so it's
both about what safely can be reopened
but also how we do that in a way that
minimises the rate of transmission the
way we think about it is this how can we
get the the the best possible positive
impact for people's lives and people and
people's livelihoods for the economy
subject to always keeping it safe and
their safety has to come first you know
there are nobody wants to see the number
of cases increase and instead what we
want to do is use local action to target
clusters and outbreaks when we see them
just to being really specific thing
because actually actually say lots of
people do need a haircut at this point
could we be going to hairdressers on
July the 4th well I'm not going to rule
that out I'm not going to rule that out
but we will set out the details as soon
as we can and what I'm trying to do is
set out the principles behind the
decisions that will take and and we'll
set them out in a in a rigorous and
formal way but you can see the direction
that we're going because we set the
direction out in the in the plan that we
published last month and and it and you
know we are clearly on track for that
plan because the number of cases is
coming down and the plan does refer to
hospitality and you know some of the
other things that are closed that that
so many people want to see open one
thing of course that lots of people want
to see reopen is pubs but the drinking
experience could be a bit different and
there's talk about potentially ordering
through an app or having to register
before you go to your local pub what
kind of things could we see well that is
the sort of thing that we're looking at
for how do
you make it's safe to to open things and
more importantly as safe as possible to
open as much as reasonably possible and
that's the that's the approach that
we're taking it's actually the approach
that many other countries around the
world are are taking and things like
wearing wearing a face mask which
reduces the the transmission very
clearly about having how the seating is
arranged because face to face is much
more dangerous than back-to-back and is
more there's more transmission than side
to side and also the sorts of the sorts
of things that you can put in place as
you mentioned to strengthen test and
trace because the whole approach is to
move as much as is safely possible from
a national lock down towards targeted
local action where we see an outbreak
for instance this specifically you could
have to register it effectively sign up
before you go to a pub well I wouldn't
rule that out it isn't a decision that
we've taken yet but there are other
countries in the world that take that
approach and there's a reason for it and
the reason that they do that is that you
then you can then if there is a positive
case and now that only you know a few
thousands of positive cases a day rather
than the many tens of thousands that the
were in the peak then you can go and
trace the people who were at risk of
being in contact that's the approach
that's working through the test and
trace process and it's an approach
that's that's being used in other
countries as well of course it's a
really difficult time for the economy
even if things are starting to gradually
reopen at revenues apparently down
around forty percent of normal levels in
shops is the Chancellor considering a
cut to VOT well that is absolutely a
matter for a budget and you wouldn't
expect me to comment either way on any
speculations on what's in a budget it's
it's very much a matter for the
Chancellor and it's very much a matter
for a budget okay but the broader point
is it
all the point that's true right which is
that the economy has taken a terrible
hit and we need to get it back on its
feet and give people the confidence to
to to get out there and we can see that
we can see that things are improving we
can see the virus is increasingly under
control there is more work to do and we
must keep it down now that we've got it
down but we must also have the
confidence to restore as much a normal
life as is safely possible that is the
normal things we people want to go back
to for instance being able to being able
to shop the clean thing of course if you
do want people to show up to spend money
to help get the economy moving again is
to convince people as you say that it's
safe to do so and a big part of that is
having the contact tracing system up and
running so as soon as new outbreaks of
infection are identified they can be
clamped down on quickly I just want to
have a little look about whether the
system is working as it should because
in the latest week for what we have
stats for 4300 people who tested
positive for cove at 19 were reached by
the intestine trade system and asked to
provide details of their contacts
so that's 4,300 contacted every week but
the ONS estimates that 4,500 people get
coronavirus every day why so many people
not being reached well the number one
thing that we need people to do is if
you have symptoms come forward for a
test because that OH&S survey which is
the best survey that there is of the
extent of coronavirus and also finds
that between 70 and 80% of people so
around three-quarters don't have any
symptoms at all so they don't know to
come forward for a test because they
don't have symptoms and that is at the
heart of the challenge of this virus
it's a natural thing of this virus that
makes it so difficult to control that
many people who are have no symptoms at
all and have the virus and can transmit
the virus so that's the main reason now
of course this
the stronger the test and tray system
gets the more of those people are
reached because they are they've got it
from somebody and that and the more
people who are tested positive out of
the total number of people who get
coronavirus they're better we will get
at being able to control it so this is
why it's so important that if you are
asked to to isolate by NHS test and
trace then you must do so because that
then breaks the chain of transmission
and at the same time we go in with local
action in places where there's a where
there's a cluster and we've talked about
some of that this week for instance
there's been a couple of manufacturing
facilities in Kirklees in Yorkshire and
we're working in Leicester where we've
got a challenge working very closely
with the local council the local
Director of Public Health at the same
for me once it seems pretty clear that
finding the contacts of these people is
absolutely critical to the system
working but a subcommittee of Sage their
scientists advising the government said
back in April a successful contact
tracing strategy would require around 30
contacts to be tested per symptomatic
case beyond that the benefits would be
marginal but the latest figures suggest
just 10 contacts are being identified by
positive case why is that happening
yes so the difference between those
figures is because of lockdown so for
those people who test positive who are
in jobs that require them to go out and
work in a normal way we're seeing around
30 contacts per person but a lot of
people are in lockdown and they tend to
only have three or four contacts
themselves so that advice was based on
analysis when there isn't a lockdown
when there is a lockdown the number of
contacts people have comes right people
it was the 20th of April so it was
during the lockdown I know but I know
that paper and it was it's based on
analysis of what happens during a when
there isn't a lockdown and the point I'm
making is that part of the purpose of
lockdown was to reduce the number of
contacts that people have
that has happened and so it that is and
so there are fewer contacts to trace of
the people who tested positive and
that's a good thing because it means
that the virus has had less chance to
spread on to other people and I'm just
delighted with the early performance of
NHS tests and trace and it has performed
really well and the vast majority of
people are engaged with it the vast
majority of people will will are
isolating say that they'll isolate when
they're asked to and this is you know
there are now over 85,000 people who are
isolating because of this system being
in place and there and so with targeting
the ice you know the need to isolate at
those who are higher risk meaning
everybody else can have some of their
freedoms back so it is exactly how the
system is intended to work you say
you're delighted with it is exactly how
it should work even though it's catching
less than one in seven people with
coronavirus now you hired 27,000 contact
races in a week they reached 40,000
contacts so they're reaching less than
two people in a whole week how is that
success so let me just pick you up on
both of those points so the first one
I've just answered this a point and that
there are many many people are
asymptomatic and explanation I
understand that you're giving the
explanation I understand that you give
an explanation for it but it's still
actually say it's clearly asymptomatic
people are slipping through how can it
be right that the contact tracers are
contacting lessen to each and a whole
week well we've got a really big system
in case we need it and on standby and so
so this is the second point I was going
to come on to having explained the point
on your of why it's hard to find all of
those asymptomatic cases and why anybody
with symptoms must come
or word the second point is we built a
big system and we don't need as big a
system now because the number of new
transmissions is lower than it was and
that is a good thing but am i pleased
that we've got excess capacity in
contact tracing you bet I am
and I'm read these stories in the
newspapers saying you know who I
terrible we've got contact tracers who
don't have enough to do well it is a
good thing to have spare capacity in
these sorts of areas the contact tracers
are doing a brilliant job and as the
number of new cases comes down across
the country and so there will be less
contact tracing to do at the same time
we want to increase the number of people
who out of the actual total number of
new transmissions we want to increase
the proportion who we find and and so
that that is why we have the capacity
there and having having spare capacity
in a in a project like this is a good
thing
okay now you said that part of the
contact tracing system would be an app
that would be crucial to of this and
would be launched by mid-may but after
three months and millions of pounds
you've had to abandon the original app
because I only recognized four percent
of Apple phones now when you launch the
trial in the Isle of Wight you said
where the Isle of Wight goes Britain
follows with hindsight would have been
you would have been useful to know that
where the Isle of Wight was going was
actually down a dead end with a app that
didn't work no on the contrary and the
we will get the app up and running and
there were two different types of
technology and we know that the the app
that we used on the Isle of Wight that
works on Android phones and Apple have a
part of their system that meant that it
wouldn't work on their phones and we
were engaged with Apple to talk about
how we could fix that problem they at
the same time later brought out their
own version with Google as soon as they
announced that we started working on
that project
as well and now we are bringing the two
together because there's problems with
their their app in terms of how it
measures distance there were clearly
problems with ours because there was a
bit of the it worked on Android and
Apple wouldn't make the change that was
needed to allow it to work on Apple so
willing gay we're engaged with them and
with Google to have a system that works
and gets the best from both sides but
I'm really on that I'm really glad that
we went down both routes as I said Don
on Thursday that we rode both horses
because it means that we can now bring
together the best of both of course I
wish we'd brought it in sooner because I
wished that we'd been able to Apple had
you know made the change that was needed
for it to work on Apple phones in the
same way that the original works on
Android phones but we will get there I
mean I can see they're kind of the
frustration if you like that Apple
didn't make the change that you thought
they could have and you know I accept
you know perhaps Apple weren't as
helpful as you would have liked them to
be but what I don't understand is why
this wasn't picked up earlier I mean it
only recognized 4% of Apple phones I
mean this isn't like a marginal
difference this is a huge number and on
the 10th of May for example dr. Michael
veal told this show the problem is that
Apple and Google Apple in particular
have said that the app doesn't work with
our operating system and so the UK is
really going against the grain and
therefore it's finding problems on both
Google and Apple phones he says he first
warned the government about this on the
11th of April I just don't understand
why don't you just listen to them why
don't you admit to fear earlier yeah
I've seen this this point being made and
there's a really simple answer to it
which is the moment that Apple and
Google brought forward their technology
we started working on that as well so
absolutely it's a perfectly reasonable
point that people make which is that
Apple have in the past also been
intransigent in the face of perfectly
reasonable requests from democratically
elected governments to work with them on
solving particular problems whether
that's about solutions to terrorism or
or other technical problems and
and so absolutely I understand that that
reluctance on their part and and to
prefer to Apple they may have good
technical reasons for it because we're
under the skin of things as soon as they
brought forward their technology we
immediately started working on that and
so a so that's why I say we wrote both
horses and that's why I'm highly
confident that we will be able to get
there and we're working on that right
now
just very quickly when are you expecting
the app to be ready well I'm not going
to put a date on it and the simple
reason is that we we don't have a launch
date and until we do I'm going to I'm
just going to work hard to get it as
soon as possible
but it will happen I'm highly confident
it'll happen but you know given my
experience over the last three or four
months on this one I'm not going to put
a date on it we're just working
incredibly hard to make it happen okay
and just very finally looking back at
the last few months the government's
record on dealing with the pandemic the
UK it's got the highest death toll in
Europe the OECD says that we will suffer
the largest economic hit of any major
economy this year we're behind many of
our neighbors on easing lockdown how can
it be that we look like we're gonna end
up with a higher death toll a longer
lockdown and a worse economic hit how is
that happened well there'll be a time
for this sort of analysis and it's it
very important in terms of ensuring that
all the lessons are learned and there's
lots of potential reasons for that
including just how open a country we are
in the amount of it the amount of
engagement that we have around the world
but you know naturally you'd expect that
ice focus and spend all of my time
focusing on the future and what we do
next
to get the economy open as much as is
safely possible and to make sure that we
keep the virus down now that we've got
the
the rates of transmission right down